the indians are facing a guy that was
tough on them last year with the chicago
white sox why because he could throw the
change up and the indians have had
trouble with that pitch all season long
yvonne nova here's frankie lindor
hitting 194 over the last eight games
squares to bunt and a good one but nova
jumps off the mound and makes a nice
play to retire lindor and a nine pitch
first for ivan nova
yeah aaron savalli he's gonna pitch for
the tribe tonight record one and two two
eight four he's been over six innings
in all of his start so far this year a
lot of action a lot of sync man on a man
out
for miguel cabrera
there goes good room
it's low
and good room is out at second base he's
in there
is he not in there i'm gonna challenge
it i think i mean he looked clearly to
have his arm in there from
he's definitely on the bay
yep there's his hand touching the bag so
he pulls it off though oh he's still got
it
yeah that's what i'm talking about how
about ron gardner
on challenges this year
1-1 to jonathan scope got jammed a
little bit sends it to left santana puts
it away tigers threatened fail to score
as we head to the second
santana with the lead off walk here to
start the second front meal reyes d.h
has hit safely in six straight games
and he drives this one in the air to
deep left center field and this ball
gone
into the shrubbery oh that is a moon
shot for front meal reyes
his third home run
and you don't see many balls
hit a couple of levels up into the shrub
rate it's two nothing cleveland
candelario sends one to deep right
center that's gonna bounce up against
the wall
puts it into a second gear and wants
third
and he will make it with ease a lead off
triple for jamer candelario here's willy
castro
castro sends it to center delano de
shields has it but it's long enough
to get the job done candelario plates
the tigers
are on the board
here we go in the tigers half of the
third jacoby jones nicole goodrum
goes the other way that's a fair ball
jones
we know the kind of speed he has
and he will cruise in with a stand-up
double to start the tigers third
nico goodram puts a charge into one into
deep right center field that ball is
gone tigers take the lead thanks to nico
goodrum's fourth splash of the year oh
baby and just like that the tigers two
batters into the third take a three-two
lead
so a walk for the tribe front meal reyes
will be the batter
oh right back up the middle indeed
coming around third here comes lindor
with the tying run and we're knotted up
at three as front meal reyes stays red
hot at the dish
santana and reyes
there now it's second and third
and making it to first here comes the
throw home safe he beat the tag oh what
a job by carlos santana he went head
first
and he beats the tag of roman and the
indians take a 4-3 lead now keep going
here's the pitch from nova it's swung on
and that's lifted high in the air deep
left field that ball is way on out of
here
beyond the bullpens home run domingo
santana it is a three-run shot
and there it is the big inning that the
indians have been looking for five on
the board here in the fourth and the
indians now lead it seven to three ron
garden hire has seen yvonne nova throw
53 pitches give up seven runs including
a couple of homers and his night is done
well aaron cevalle
bottom of the fifth inning has jacoby
jones the number nine hitter to lead off
what a pitch there you go stayed with
the breaking stuff there's the rotation
he's getting that pitch down in the zone
exactly like his last start with that
curveball against chicago
nice sequence wow that's really good
pitching by savali tonight he's only
struck out three
row mine a couple of homers on the
season
201 goes the other way that's going to
drop
candelario will score and willie castro
holds it second
that's a pros pro right there as austin
romine comes through
and the tigers
get to within four
here's tyler and aquin two out two on
seventh inning eight to four indians the
pitch
swing and a line shot toward the gap in
the left center it gets down for a hit
it's going all the way to the wall
ramirez scores front meal reyes he is on
his way home digging for third is nake
went in sliding with a two run triple
and the indians now lead this game
10 to four
two down in the ninth tigers down to
their last out
dominic leone strikes him out to end the
ball game and the indians go to the
motor city and continue their domination
of the tigers they beat him for the 18th
time in a row
and they do it emphatically here tonight
by a final of 10 to 5.